this is what they want the pattern of
Demands is a constitutionally required
statement of General objectives these
are the general objectives
increase minimum compensation
significantly to address the devaluation
of writing in all areas of Television
New Media and features
no we can't do that not one weekend too
that's I'm speaking now for I'm speaking
now
because I know because these are my
friends the billionaires I'm speaking
now for them because I wear the glasses
that they wear do you understand do you
have a furry Polo thing that's 3x
and it was bought in a bin they're nice
I'm going to tell you what we can do and
what we cannot do
this doesn't mean I'm I'm I'm the person
who's representing the billionaires but
I'm for the writers
so it's easy to get confused here
I'm in solidarity with the the
Communists that don't want to work
I'm kidding it's a comedy podcast I'm in
solidarity with writers but I'm
representing the billionaires in this
exercise to help everybody come to the
table do you understand yes or yes you
get it right I want the writers to win
even though many of them have called me
a Nazi on Twitter I want the writers to
win but I'm also representing the
billionaires first first event increased
minimum compensation significantly that
cannot know
that is not going to happen I understand
why you would want that
we are not going to do that
standardized compensation and residual
terms for features whether released
theatrically or on streaming this is an
interesting one also no
also no because we can't
if it's on streaming or if it's in the
feature it's different
it's we don't know what's going how
it'll all play out so what we need to do
is not establish any type of uniform
standard about how much money you should
get paid address the abuses of many
rooms now I like this we can do this put
them now many rooms mean tiny little
rooms of tiny writers and they're abused
because they're small and they put them
in a small place and nobody likes that
we can do a larger room for them and I
think that's we can put in the contract
right now many rooms become major rooms
or Mega rooms
we'll take five or six Riders and we'll
put them in a very large room and let
them do what they want but
we we cannot pay them anymore ensure
appropriate television series writing
compensation throughout the entire
process of pre-production production and
post-production meaning from the from
the pilot
to the to the you know oh we're gearing
up to do it to the actual doing of it to
so this is it's kind of like when you
think about abortion with the chart and
you go you know 15 weeks and this and
that and you know post-production is
like late term abortion
here's what I think about this
I think
we can
we can make sure ensure appropriate
television series writing compensation
throughout the entire process
we can't do it for the entire process
from the people that I've spoken to
we can do it for a week
any week you want and I think this is a
good thing whether it's pre-production
post-production
actual production
we will for one week during the
production
make sure you're appropriately
compensated for one week during the
process
any the week is up to you
but if it takes
17 weeks or something to get something
happening it's we can't one week we'll
do it expand span protections to cover
all television writers I don't know what
that is and I so we're not doing it
apply MBA minimums to Comedy variety
programs made for New Media like
should a show on Snapchat about two
people that are dating despite one of
them not having a face
because they're on Snapchat you've seen
these shows where the person's face
caves in but they have a wife and
they're in India
I think that's what this is talking
about I don't know what I imagine this
is talking about is that's a new uh type
of uh New Media Snapchat and that's a
comedy variety show now some sick Fox
will find it funny but it's really a
variety program it's like it'll be a man
who's like a snake it's like he has no
bones and he's a snake with a head but
he has a kind of a regular looking wife
she ain't great but those are the shows
on Snapchat one of them is called Born
different and it's like somebody who's
just goes I don't have a nervous system
but I'm here and this is my wife
and they're saying should people get
paid to write those I don't know
but maybe I kind of enjoy them sometimes
so maybe we'll give them money for that
increased residuals for under
compensated reuse markets like when it's
you know the thing is we're going to use
it again
no
uh pension plan and health fund
increased contributions to pension plan
and health fund here's the thing
no but because too many of them smoke
cigarettes
too many writers I see in the Silver
Lake Echo Park area are always smoking
cigarettes outside of a cafe
I don't think we can increase the
contributions to the health plan
for future contracts okay some of this
is boring
we gotta do something here where we're
like let's
like we're not getting rid of chat GPT
you're not getting rid of AI like a lot
of people are going
we want no AI that's what they want
right no AI That's not realistic we can
do no people from the Netherlands
like no
Dutch people in a writer's room
we can exclude races of people much
easier than we can exclude
artificial intelligence because that's
just the that's the new game in town but
we could say like no Eastern Europeans
because they creep everyone out that's
fair
let's negotiate along those terms
now
what are the top shows on TV right now
this is how we're gonna make this
decision because sag is going to strike
the union I'm a member of I'm the Screen
Actors Guild I'm an actor on the screen
like unlike many of you
I'm an actor on the screen and I'm and
I'm participating in uh
in many of different projects right now
um
so I don't know I'm just saying
I'm looking at these shows and this is
what that beef with that Ali Wong she's
done well huh why don't I have more
Asian fans to be honest
all I do is talk about China how much I
love China my Chinese godson and you
know Matt Rife they're saying has all
these Asian fans
this is what I'm being told is Matt Rife
now is huge in China and I'm nowhere
I'm not I like Matt Rife but does he
know who president Z is
I do nothing but advocate for Z
and I have nothing
no Asians come very few Asians one Asian
fan to me is worth a thousand whites
true so if you come to my show
and you're Asian man I am
um I'm happier than you'll ever know
well I hope the writer's strike is okay
I don't know what's gonna happen but I
I'm just saying that it's going to be
it's going to be pretty difficult to get
everybody to the table because I think
when the writers have a good point these
streamers are making a lot of money
let's see what all of these people make
because the writers keep focusing on the
CEOs of these companies like David
zazlov and uh Ted surrandos hit Netflix
shout out to Ted my specials on there
I'm not even talking to these hoes Ted
but
you know everybody is like
you know what's the average salary of a
TV writer in America 62 000 a year
that's the average yeah
that's not great
but I know a lot of them that make a lot
more but I I understand what they mean
they want more money
it's fair now go to there's a chart here
that'll show you what all the CEOs of
the streamers make you can easily find
it because
that's what these writers are saying
they're like why should this guy who's
running Warner Brothers make more than
me
I'm the fourth writer on Abbott
Elementary
why should the guy who runs Warner
Brothers make more money than me I wrote
on a failed pilot three years ago about
a gym teacher
who discovered uh uh square dancing and
got all the kids to square dance and
Hulu bought it but it didn't work and I
don't know why I don't also have a yacht
our Emmanuel CEO of endeavor 308 million
David zaslav discover CEO and this is
what they all made last year 246 million
Bob Iger 45 million Bob trade pack
Disney 32 million igers Disney as well
Murdoch 31 million at Fox Reed Hastings
40 million at Netflix sarando's 38
million at Netflix Brian Roberts Comcast
CEO 30
million they're doing hey they're doing
well they're doing well and
I understand the writers going we want
more
because they're getting they're getting
a lot of money they're making a lot of
money the discovery CEO this guy David
zazlev 250 million last year he did well
how did he make that much money what
happened over there
who even watches discovery
there's got to be something else he's
got to have something else going on
is he Warner he's Warner Brothers too
right Discovery CEO David zazlov what
does he do
can't just be discovery
yeah he was oh yeah so it's Warner Bros
Discovery yeah yeah well that yeah of
course okay
he's the CEO Warner Brothers and all
these writers are mad and I get it and
Adam Conover is going why does he have
the money and I don't I did the the show
where I talk about people's water
I understand that he's because I talk I
do the show where I talk about where
people's water comes from and that's
good
but he's gonna have a little more than
you but I think Conover should be given
more money for this show he did about
um
what it was the Adam ruins everything
where he'd go in and somebody would go I
think uh I don't know what that he would
like expose things he'd be like the
suburbs are racist and people would be
like
okay and then he would talk to tell you
how
and that's fun
that's fun and it's funny
it's funny and it's fun
and that's the type of programming
people will pay to see
that's what I pay to see when I'm
sitting at home after a long day I want
to know about how racist the suburbs are